started as an idea what if we made a
Deadpool movie there's only a few of us
back then and looking back we had no
idea how big it would become so innocent
and yet the momentum that had started
Yetta was not really what we had in mind
nope that didn't help things
it was more of a hell no to be honest
and we eventually stopped asking we have
no idea how that happened but I promise
you I'm looking into it well what's the
movie got greenlit I went on a massive
coke bender
so 2016 Nestle hazy for me they tell me
the movie did well though 10 years into
it
phase one has exceeded our wildest
expectations you know if you told me
back then at one movie would spawn an
expansive - movie universe I'd have said
that you were crazy but here we are with
actual actors a moderate special effects
budget and several low-level x-men none
of the big ones though we got to save
something for Phase two
believe it or not Deadpool 2 is a family
film
can you come out I have to go its my
anniversary
there's this kid he's in trouble
Russell right fire first that kids got a
terrible name it's awful
I've tried to tell him he's always yet
here's the plan oh go tall baby kid
could all make a super baby pretty sure
it doesn't work that way but we can try
okay Maxo no matter what you are Susu
are sorry when Samson went out and each
of them Dajjal
you